what you mean and is that I'm leaving
and he's he's crying any stress
[Music]
subscribe on YouTube follow us on C now
follow us on Twitter
follow us on Instagram follow us on
every other social media platform for
loss of Pedro and go and patron and
search it's a gigs
follow us on zim zam we're on the zim
zam now what the [ __ ] is that
yeah no bazooms I'm I signed us up to
Zim Zam the new tick-tock never heard of
it doesn't exist I made out that's just
how I feel sometimes you know we do the
introduction tennis I'll tell everyone
the resume and this is gonna be a next
thing on a next thing in the next ring
true
I've also got a few is snow released
I'll much say if you click on it's gonna
be a link below but if you're gonna
Instagram page click on link tree you'll
see it there as well be blessed if you
guys do support us and if you do buy any
comms please take a pic and tag us when
you buddy comes when you buy like when
you buy the Comstock because as soon as
you see the website you're gonna want to
buy the guns but now we appreciate all
the love as per as we see out every
episode so thank you thank you
[ __ ] thank you but yeah man I do for
you this is for you 141 bro do you know
talk to me
bugs from mm-hmm bugs bugs I hate bugs
mm-hmm I agree [ __ ] hate but it's bugs
see obvious bug season right now I can't
stand bugs I'm not afraid of them but I
[ __ ] hate them I detest them I don't
know why they exist I don't know more
about the cycle of life what in their
regards yes it all died I hate bugs
I hate him mark the amount of times I
think last week or so obviously cos was
it's been boiling recently he leave the
windows I mean we've had flies galore in
this galore we just stop Ian now we're
using pillows to kill him off yeah [ __ ]
it here bro flies are the worst flies
and Hajj do you know what's the worst
flying ants
I've not seen those in years probably
the only come out one like one day yeah
I'm not seeing those in years honey only
come out now one day year and when they
do they're just in swarm found in
unstoppable scariest moment my life the
first out months cover them really fan
I'm a staff at as well when they pop
when you hit a minute they're the worst
creature I can I can never forget the
first time I saw one well now this was a
little now when I was living the Crystal
Palace obviously was hot it was June
summertime I saw them in in the garden
and I was thinking oh [ __ ] these are
ants but they look big neela has been a
big I had wings I'm speaking what the
[ __ ] of ease hmm when did God made these
do you not I mean yes I knew all these
flying about a Lincoln oh my god these
[ __ ] have evolved bro that is
what Flannery is that's evolution that's
[ __ ] enough as they are oh my god as
they are as they are already what do
they say the wait yeah this that the
wait if you if you get every ant on the
planet altogether and weigh it it would
weigh more than every human on the
planet that's outrageous is outrageous
antilles nothing an ant does we know and
that literally weighs nothing less than
paper oh my god and you get them all
together and they were more than us no
that's too many
there's billions of ants in the world
bro and they work in force will you see
them doing their thing you like now
these men have an ulterior motive
these men have an ulterior motive
they're David's they're evolving
themselves cuz they've got their own
little ecosystem and they're gonna turn
against us they're doing bits out their
answer doing bit and the thing we fry
enhance they're like three times the
size of regular ants they're they're
massive big they're massive and they
have no regard for personal space
they will lick you in your head you're
just walking at a famine and it's just
like they don't care bro
I [ __ ] hate insects of the worst
thing in the world bro I tell you the
work of King the king the king of
insects that's the cockroaches I've got
those in ages I've only seen one
cockroach one time ever in my life
really and it was the scariest
experience I've ever had yeah
so check this one of you paid a picture
story time I love stst yeah
so it's me hmm I must have told you
story before but I'll tell you it get
any detail right so it's me my friend
Kier
I'm a friend man over an I in Napa mmm
so let me paint the picture we were in I
Napa for two [ __ ] weeks no one on
planet earth should ever go to either
for two weeks long you shouldn't even go
for a week you go for four days man you
give it your all and you [ __ ] off home
yeah two weeks I I was I was close to
tears on the phone my mama how homesick
I was I was close to tears
I just didn't want to do it anymore do
you know he said about the Hat afro
nation and you just couldn't do it
anymore from two weeks of iron upper I
physically didn't have it in me anymore
I was so sleep-deprived so dehydrated
he's hot there mm-hmm
he's hot yeah it's a different kind of
hot yeah he's a different kind of hot in
Ayia Napa broth it's hot oh sure so and
we were just so destroyed on this day so
we must have gone out like I'm saying
we've gone at this point this must be
like day eight or nine and we've been at
it from there from day one and we've hit
every night hard and we're like guys we
all we all acknowledged like guys
tonight
please let's stay in mmm let's just go
for a walk yeah dinner yeah have an
early night when I say early I could
have been a bed by 9:00 fun I was [ __ ]
I wasn't I
was so depressed I needed to go home and
I was like human have no idea how
excited I am for this night in and these
men I'd like bro me [ __ ] to like I'm
so excited so we get up we get dressed
we take a walk down to the strip just do
a quick lap don't go in anywhere I'm
saying hi to a couple people that would
seem been meeting stuff yeah grab dinner
went the [ __ ] home yeah go back in the
hotel room we were in a ground-floor
hotel room right get back in a hotel
room a we're chilling and we'll go
through the cameras when this is back a
day so this was I was 20 so this is when
we su had a purpose for a camera because
phone cameras were trashed yeah oh yeah
it's nine years ago yeah phone cameras
were trash I don't know iPhone stuff but
like it was the trial was test crash and
you couldn't just be taking big big big
big baby baby picture your memory
marathon yeah so I actually had a
digital camera [ __ ] world i digital
camera with me and we're just going
through the picture somewhere laughing
in the videos were just howling there's
bear funny [ __ ] thumb and as we're
laughing giggling I'm starting to get
tired and everyone started to wind down
and I'm like oh what a perfect evening
yeah as I'm talking I literally look
across the floor and I see just look and
it was quicker than I've ever seen and I
was like I don't want to alarm this man
but I'm I'm certain that was a cockroach
yeah I'm certain I've never seen
anything like it and it moved with
intent yeah he knew where it went from
point A to point B he knew where he was
going yeah he's been here a minute yeah
so I looked it and I was like I think
that was a cockroach and no idea was
good and I was like fellas don't want to
alarm anyone but I think I just saw a
cockroach and there man were like nah I
did it and I was like fam I think I
[ __ ] did I never like to swear down
so we actually looked for it
and we were like I categorically
couldn't find it and it was a room like
this like it can't hide nowhere like if
it ain't under the beds or the luggage
ain't nowhere hmm so we literally are we
literally couldn't find it so actually
we look to an extent that I I was at
ease even though I know I've seen it I
was at ease thinking maybe it is it
because it's clearly not here cuz it's
[ __ ] fat and I was like alright cool
my maybe my eyes are playing tricks on
me so we carry on and we
so to put it in perspective my bed was
over here there's three single beds but
two of the beds were pushed together as
that these man was sleeping on these two
beds pushed together and I had a single
bed over here and it was like let's call
it like six seven feet apart it was a
fair distance or floor space between the
three beds right so we're chilling and I
just jump over these men so we can all
huddle up and we're catching jokes and
obviously that's all past we've looked
for it can't find it
everything's blessed didn't happen firm
we're chillin chillin chillin and I'm
just like yeah yeah yeah I look and I
see the thing he-he-hey next to my leg
BAM next to my [ __ ] leg is here when
I say I screamed to the top of my lungs
and the octaves were high and I I I must
have broken skin on these man because I
grab chest
I just clawed her whatever I could to
get away I've never been so scared in my
[ __ ] life I clawed at skin from my
claudus kid to get away and I left and
when I say I made the 7 foot jump 1
strike 1 strike easy
bang I was over there don't touch the
floor mmm I was an athletic feat and I
just made it and I was like and then I
don't know what the [ __ ] are you doing
and I couldn't say I couldn't see it
he was social I was just like you're a
grown human and my voice was breaking I
was trying to say so human cockroach
[ __ ] cockroach but you know gay you
know gay cockroach and act now we're and
I was like on the [ __ ] bed cars move
got away got away
Oh Gilligan bed and these minor paddocks
row these are gonna put the sheets light
everywhere everyone's getting onto the
bed and then same thing again from we
couldn't find it we couldn't find it I
don't know
dude his [ __ ] a quick yes much power down
sorry about that guys yeah sorry cuz my
bad um fam we couldn't find the thing
and I'm like geez man I think I'm lying
again again these might actually the
antenna and everything I'm not lying I'm
not making [ __ ] up there's a cockroach
in here we need to find it and kill it
from every month panicked and them
longer we can't find it the more stress
ensues of course of more stress ensues
of course and these men are like now now
where is it where is it and now
everyone's tensions are high firm then
we're looking looking looking I see it
on the side of a mattress and it dot
when I say I'm like you guys dead and
they all see you and then it's like he
could understand us because as soon as
we saw it he went back under the bed
with intent he knows where he's going he
knows his layout now he knows he's not
just like [ __ ] around
like when I fly's escaping you he's
going all over the place it doesn't know
where it's going it just wants to get
away
this man knew where to go and when to go
there he dip straight under the bed and
I screamed tubes up my lungs so me a
cure on my bed and grabbing each other's
you know how we grab each other
grabbing each other's hands and shaking
and he was screaming like yeah it's like
top tier yeah so we twenty-year-old men
will grab it and screaming and meanwhile
meanwhile mama got his suitcase out from
under the bed here put it on the bed and
his tears nozzles enough he sighs
grabbing his clothes and pack in the
suitcase
then we're like he's like I'm going to a
different room and I'm like what room
does what do you mean I knew that I'm
leaving and he's he's crying any stress
and this time I'm so scared I'm laughing
so hard because big man is in tears this
is our back in asuka is in it in a pie
Nik oh I need a [ __ ] leave they've
gotta get me another room and I've got
no money you can't get enough room
inside they're gonna get me another room
I'm not staying here and the clothes are
flying in there like to the point he's
slamming it shot he's going and then we
see the cockroach come across the floor
kid and he leaves on its bed no starting
on the beds and a little screaming well
screaming cross with screaming we need
him to leave we need to reverse the [ __ ]
off we can't get it and then we all had
to elect oh we took a minute we're all
standing on beds and we just like have
to kill it we can't get enough room Abby
can't even get off the bed now she's too
scared to even leave yeah he's too
scared to get off the bed yeah so he's
in turmoil and I'm laughing bomb also
[ __ ] terrified yeah so we can't he's
dipped again and we fought we've
cornered him this is the [ __ ] peek
ting we saw him go under the double bed
so we know where he ain't now so we're
like all right he's under the bed mom
jump over here this corner I'm a fool
let's open the patio door so it went my
bed against the wall so you come into
the room here my beds here there's floor
space then there's the double bed and
then there's a patio doors on the other
side there's like we're gonna have to
get him out that way so we all come over
to my bed we set up a browser and we
move forward I'm like cool let's slide
the first bed out of the way and he's
gonna have to hide under the second bed
and if he comes out we're gonna have to
do it ting so me and my grabbed the bed
and were like Kia have a brew he's got
broom ready you're gonna have to do site
on site yeah so we get it out the bed
pull out the bed he had there so were
like all right cool
I'm gonna check under he's under this
one so now Kia's got the broom we've run
run we open the patio doors and why this
is it Kia
we're gonna flip the [ __ ] bed as soon
as you seem you need to scoot him and
our man was like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so we're gonna say okay well good
on three I'm I was like
and we're like no you have to yeah he's
uh I'm telling you I can't bro where's
it coming from
yeah we need you yeah we have to pull
the bed and you have to get him out he's
like you man ain't getting it beside you
man a following I can't
I'm not saying I worked I'm saying I
can't I can't do it we're now we argue
with we fully hug anger we're all angry
aim but you have to please please and
then were like fine you pull the bed out
there then he said I can't do that
I'm not having my toes under the bed
where I know he is I can't do it then
then prove him out I can't
and he's panicked he's frozen yeah he's
frozen now he can't do anything oh my
god so we're like [ __ ] you bro we're
gonna pull his bed and you're gonna have
to [ __ ] do it you're gonna have to
[ __ ] doing and he's like [ __ ] if I do
it
fam we yank off the bed and we're like
go go go yeah go to bed he ain't there
he ain't there now I'm scared oh good
now I'm scared because I don't know
where where the [ __ ] is he is we had the
whole room sauced and he did not leave
we saw him go under the bed we've pulled
out the beds he ain't [ __ ] there and
he is nowhere to be seen from there's
not a space he can hide yeah I'm so
scared and family it oh this this has
gone on for hours yeah it's 3:00 in the
morning did you find her - once it's
have an early night we wanted to have an
early stressful night it's 3:00 in the
[ __ ] morning and we can't find him
yeah so now we off to order that we've
convinced ourselves he's probably gone
he probably went out because we'd
[ __ ] can't find him he's nowhere to
be seen
yeah we've been looking for ages now so
we finally get the room back together
we're just about to go to bed fam I've
brushed my teeth and I'm like this is
the worst night of my [ __ ] life big
man just as I step out towards my bed he
scurries out from under my bed
before I can let out a breath
Kia's got his shoe in his hand and makes
the most clutch
I've ever seen anyone do he has a shoe
in his hand and he didn't like slam it
on him he'd lost his shoe mm-hmm and it
landed flat he landed flat on it I had
just done him he just done the cockroach
then and there like a [ __ ] hero oh my
was accurate or he was nowhere near it
like he just I just saw him drop a bra
bang and he just want and it done him
and then Matt was like big man when you
crush it there lay their eggs mmm so I'm
there with the [ __ ] spray and we all
I think we all had like a can of bug
spray and we're spraying for like 10
minutes straight we need the whole thing
done fumigated Zam we fumigated the
whole room that's the worst experience
and ah it was just another night ruined
and then the next time we went out again
it was the worst night of my life
do you know what's so funny that story
first of all you've never told us that
before oh really and that is the one of
the funny stories ever told me because
for something so small to be such it's
of course such so much drama in a night
is hilarious that's comedy bro the
fingers like obviously people have
listed his nose I've scored and lived in
Nigeria for two years two and a half
years I could do it carry on so for me
like when you say stuff like cockroaches
and stuff I've seen cockroaches before
granted I still hate them but because of
the the the frequency at which I used to
see them back then mmm if I if I wasn't
with you in iron up her after Nigeria
that would have faze me as much I would
have been equally as annoyed slash
scared yeah but I would have more time
handled it or dealt with it as soon not
sooner than you man did yeah much you
didn't Amanda it took us five hours plus
because not only do you have cockroaches
obviously we've got mosquitoes all over
the gaff
you've got war geckos do you know I mean
so it's like I can't live like that big
man I used to live in a boarding house
and they used me like six beds in a room
per room mm-hmm
there'll be war geckos in the room
because they come through like that in
every room does aircon unit so they come
for you that you nateing
because there's some s'mores someone
really big we just see him and it's like
obviously when I'll say the first time I
saw all of this obviously because I came
fresh from England yeah tonight sure
it's not like I came from fresh from AJ
to England yeah so that would have been
a better transition yeah mine went from
a great transition it's not seeing any
of this yeah to see in this are you in a
fairly the beast from day today I've
never had to adjust my life to such
society in my entire life I mean you
know we have to acclimatize so quick or
you're gonna die yeah yeah but the thing
is thinking about thinking back about it
now I didn't actually realise how quick
I to acclimatize things I did feel the
change yeah yeah yeah you know I mean
but if you take someone to go and do
that now panic wouldn't you hundred a
big man I've seen war geckos in my is
normal how could I could is not fab just
dead and I'm not getting them out I'm
not going near room oh yeah I'm not
staying in that room and I figured wall
geckos I don't think they're dangerous
in the slightest I'm sure then I don't
what why is it - reptiles in the house
in the yard lizards on the walls in the
house I can't sleep like this I can't
sleep like this at my fam this is why in
my head in the future this is my dream
right yeah in my head we obviously we've
already spoken about eventually we're
gonna start doing live shows yes
so we're gonna start going into places
yeah and doing these live yeah can't
wait for it yeah by the time we make it
over to Australia no one will want
anything to do with me because I'm gonna
be so gassed yeah we'd land [ __ ]
Australia I've always want to come here
yeah yeah yeah this [ __ ] everyone's
buff for some reason everyone's piff the
the Seas blue yeah everything the side
is white everything's amazing
everything's amazing everyone stand like
I'm gas
screens alone Victoria I'm there bro
we're here Sydney the whatnot
we're here where are you fam all it
would take for me is when whoever's
giving us a tour of whatever we're doing
I turn and I see a lizard on the wall
outside
I'm like cool I've seen that before I've
seen that on holidays before cool I can
handle that then I'm seeing spiders
spiders and not English spies yeah real
man's real fighters and people are oh
don't let that touch you
I'll kill you pardon that spider if it
bites you'll die but don't worry like
first of all they're rare and second of
all they'd already come in the house
and third of all all these wives tales
you don't know what the spiders gonna do
yeah this is a [ __ ] spider sort of
tell me don't tell me you're gonna do
this in that you don't know what he's
gonna do but it okay spider
all right cool fine that's bless cool go
to the bus [ __ ] make sure you check
toilet before you brush it because it
snakes and [ __ ] in the top climb up the
toilets so make sure you check toilet
twice full bus [ __ ] and what you mean
snake yeah sometimes things get through
the sewage system and they go for the
pipe and then there's been a couple
times maybe once once a year twice a
year that's knit will come up and bite
your [ __ ] from the toilet okay so
hang on there's lizards everywhere
there's [ __ ] black widows that can't
touch apparently they won't bite me but
if they do they'll die sometimes there's
snakes in the [ __ ] toilet that might
bite my [ __ ] and then I die yes
okay cool cool we're gonna go oh there's
a pool here so whenever you guys want to
use the pool that's fine
just dump into poor that's all use okay
cool but be careful if you see anything
in there look out for alligators cuz
sometimes alligators sneak under the
fence they see the wall obviously
alligators doing alligator [ __ ] they get
in the [ __ ] war and there's an
alligator in your pool hang on hang on
okay let's pull back this is outside
that's fine
there's blood weirdest part is that my
cure would be they probably weren't I
need to check the [ __ ] toilet before
I take a [ __ ] because this [ __ ] snake
that might come in there by my [ __ ]
and when I want to go for a dip I need
to be careful for alligators Gator in
his territory [ __ ] me up that's
correct
cool let's go Beach I want to see
titties and tan yeah I'm tired of this
talk let's go Beach alright calm let's
go Beach
you might want to go jet skiing yes
please let's go Jets kid cool make sure
you don't fall off though because this
time here's a cup of great
White's couple great white sand tiger
sharks that like the war war this time
of year so it never really happens but
just if you see that if you see the
lifeguard or the brook if the lifeguard
blows whistle place get means there's a
shark you can get out get the [ __ ] out
and I'm like what's this isn't a holiday
well where can I go what can I do
this is Hunger Games fantasy I'm not
leaving the hotel not leaving the hotel
there's no show there the show's [ __ ]
canceled families [ __ ] cancelled guys
we're not doing the show and I'm sorry
kangaroos come to their doorsteps as
well in my the Outbacks full-blown
kangaroos
there's a guy I follow on tick-tock I
think his name is Joey something or
joelle something he's a Australian
tick-tock ha and he always says if you
value your life then blower or don't do
this don't do that
he's [ __ ] hilarious but some of the
things he talks about in Australia
obviously is Australian and he he warns
us about like the top three animals you
need to be afraid of or two top three
this and the top three that and it's
like this is the norm for them I'm not
dealing with that this is the norm for
them so like for example like when I
said to you how your story about the
cockroach in iron upper and I was like
that was normal feed in Nigeria so my
response would have been totally
different series was granted I still
would have been annoyed / scared but my
response would be indifferent but the
fact that that's their norm alligators
[ __ ] spiders snakes kangaroos war
geckos bro all sorts they got moths this
big moths
remember that time I told you a story
about them didn't matter if they imagine
if the muscle are fast not moths sloths
oh yes massive scurrying along after you
Broyles there's moths out there that
have wingspan like if it bruised past
you you'll probably feel a breeze like
that no I you have no idea that James
you'd me if that was ever the case if
one of them things just flew in here
right now I will break if anything the
podcast is counsels on smashing
everything I need to get out yeah and if
he's blocking the door I'm going on the
way
there's certain things that ensue such
panic in me that I'm not me anymore yeah
you're not willing to grow and Australia
Australia would do that to me yeah
Australia would do that to me the thing
is I'm still want to go there so you
wanna go there so bad but fam I'll be so
scared so scared I don't want to do all
the water sports mmm but sharks are my
biggest fear I have I'm scared of a
couple of things obviously like phobia
of birds and all that stuff
sharks mmm big man anything in the water
my big my biggest fear like I go into
like shock mmm there's been times where
I've been on holiday there's been times
where I've been on hunt there's one time
I remember I was on holiday with my mom
and then I remember I was I had like a
fear I fear a little fear of the sea
just because of [ __ ] that's in the sea
yeah I would never want to be in a sea
from this there's see [ __ ]
this stuff that lives in that water that
we've never seen you've never seen you
rough and I remember saying to my mum
I'm not joking like I'm I'm I'm scared
and I'm a common reasonable human being
like I'm not scared of [ __ ] I'm not
scared of heights and I'm not scared of
doing stuff but found there was
something about the war I know somehow
I'm not gonna lie I'm [ __ ] scared
I've got I don't wanna get in there this
[ __ ] in there that I don't want to me
and she was like you're being so stupid
paranoid yeah you're being so paranoid
like we were in Spain for [ __ ] sake like
and then C is like hip length like hip
height just get in the [ __ ] seat my
prob bro I took one step one step in
there I looked at my right and there's a
crowd of people literally like 2 feet
away from me they're just everyone's
crowd another [ __ ] of the crowd enough
about I gather war I look it's a fat
[ __ ] jellyfish that just washed up on
shore and I was like I'm done with the
sea I'm done with the sea before I even
get started was that Jenny Fisher could
arrive around my [ __ ] leg he's in
Spain he's in Spain might mild Spain Wow
and I was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that so
fast for two another time I was I was I
think I was in Spain again with my dad
and then he wanted to go bananaboy
obviously you know banana boy yeah yeah
obviously so yeah we will go banana
blossom [ __ ] you I want to go banana
bird so I'm
lost in the fun yeah of course I'm lost
in the fun and then Donnie in the
speedboat does a sharp turn and I fly
off ah very much fun fear from it was
fun and then I was like ah I got in
there and I'm just like gassed and I'm
like oh that's crazy and obviously these
men are circling back to come and get me
whilst they come and get me I look down
and I can't see [ __ ]
yeah we're real worn out yeah we're real
sea water yeah I look down I can't see a
[ __ ] thing and I'm thinking how deep
is this mmm this is deep deep deep hmm
and my legs are just dangling here from
I froze if I didn't have a live shot gun
I was sunk yeah because I couldn't move
yeah and I was just waiting for my leg
to get bit yeah
and in my head asked me good there's a
shot below right [ __ ] now and she's
gonna grab my [ __ ] leg
miss bring him back like an emotional
reactions I mean I've never felt so
panicked Wow never felt so panic time to
look into water that I can't see [ __ ] in
and then you there's bear [ __ ] in there
yeah there's bear [ __ ] that live in the
sea crazy [ __ ] that lives in the sea if
anything would have just scraped past my
toe
the whole continent would have known
about this scream I will put down I
think I would have had a heart attack I
think I would die of cardiac arrest good
then and there bro I'm scared of the sea
sharks are my biggest [ __ ] fear [ __ ]
I've ever seen shot no and I never
actually know I've seen I've seen sharks
in aquariums I've never seen one like
face to face face to face have you no no
no no just asking never I don't [ __ ]
wait to see like that no bro I don't
like to swim all that and if I do go to
a beach resort kind of holiday I would
swim in like the shore bit where I
couldn't still kind of you know find my
bearings I'm not going in today ting
deep well go in there we need when the
war gets cold because that water I was
in the bananaboy time they were cold
that's how you know the Sun hold
founded the light can't penetrate
deepened and I was just like [ __ ] I'm
gonna get eaten but I'm not I'm not
doing it bro I don't know how these
might do it there are some things in
life I rather not
I like understand the beauty of it in
terms of life hmm
going deep-sea divers go scuba diving
like that it's fascinating but you might
can do ni kawatte from the TV web apps
covered because tell me what you saw
when we come back show me the pictures
that you took it's exactly why I see if
my fear of death is so soon ominous to
my love of life do you know I mean it
always boils down to that I love life so
much I am not willing to risk my life
for your pleasure I don't give a [ __ ]
what's down there you could tell me the
cure for cancers down there go in there
bro you might could go find that yeah
when you bring it back we can pie yeah
I'm not going in there I'm not coming in
there
I hate scuba divers my worst nightmare
worst nightmare and I can understand why
people think it's so cool and I do think
it's cool and I wish I wanted to do it
but there's no way in [ __ ] there's no
hell I'm doing it Fabio submarine yeah
would mmm I would I wouldn't find it as
cool though got in a submarine
I wouldn't I'll be scared still I would
never go in a submarine Oh be scares you
need sort of submarines they go lower
than no injury they go they go like you
can't see the light yeah okay when you
look like you're saying that I'm not
going in a summit that's like go please
break you're basically going out of
space yeah yeah it's like saying going
on a plane and they're going on a rocket
I'm not going on a rocket so I'm not
going on a submarine I mean they go deep
thumpers pressure down there scientists
don't go on rockets yeah crazy people go
on rockets yes scientist just build them
yeah you might get going if you want
bring about what you find yeah firm I'm
the scientist I'm not coming in there
I'm an I'm an inhabitant on mother earth
[ __ ] man I fear death I fear death oh my
love of life is so synonymous to the
fear of death I don't think you might
get the thing is I envy the
free-spirited sometimes yeah like people
like Jay Jay loves doing crazy laughs to
do crazy [ __ ] like he he bungee jumped
on his birthday like three years ago I'm
cool when he's sky dived in to buy life
thinking that's [ __ ] sick I envy that
I do I don't want to die can't get me on
that plane as much as I'd love to see it
you can't get me on that plane I've
always said I'm gonna have to get
someone to book a sky there for me
because I've always wanted to do it but
I'm not booking not yeah well I can't
like I'm that I might [ __ ] die cause
you're jumping out of a plane now and if
I don't die from something happening I'm
dying of heart I'm brokers I'm scared
I'm scared there's the art a the people
with bollocks there's always the
obviously sky dev is one thing when
you're attached to Donnie who's the pro
yes that's one thing people who want to
learn how to do it by themselves
yeah no oh god no no not good not the
first time the first time I have to do
it by myself they've done I've taken the
course but a two-day course I've taken
the course and I've learned all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I need to know and then
they're like cool let's do the first
flight I'm I'm not thinking it's like
I'm breaking down what like family I
will hold the I will hold the thing and
I'll end up dying because as soon as I
jump out pulling it I know you could
learn everything to a tee on the two day
course and be like yep I'm ready as soon
as you go by yourself for everything
goes I don't as soon as I jump out of
the plane I'm yanking it and the engine
shutting me out
[Music]
and the second my foot leaves that ledge
I'm yeah that's all my Mike Donnie yeah
and he bare bullet when he's supposed to
pull it because I'm gonna be screaming
from Ernie John Yankee we'd be falling
for hours pull it is the safe [ __ ] die
on your own day bullet was it you that
told me someone's told me that I know
what you want to say I probably do you
mean you know I'm gonna say the
instructor yeah that commits suicide
yeah whilst happens on my son of a [ __ ]
yeah fam I would tell Donnie when he's
when my life is strapped to him I will
say to him show me your family
show me your reasons to live yeah cuz I
don't trust you I don't know you bro I
don't [ __ ] know you show me three
back friends you have I don't want to
see pictures yeah and show me your
family hmm show me the ones you love and
tell me what you love about life because
if you tell me in midair hold this nah
nah when you say this is the way I want
to die and I'm attached to you I'll be
so angry my eyes would roll out my head
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] why you've got any day
to do this
why do it with me you could have done
this what yourself ah why are you doing
this to me you [ __ ] are we so angry for
us so for context a an instructor and
another guy were jumping out of dropping
off a helicopter or where he is a plane
playing into a bungee job obviously the
guy was strapped to the instructor
skydive skydive bungee I said budget up
then skydive the guy was attached to it
the instructor they jumped out and the
my man said you you've got this on your
own now cuz I'm about to die I'm ready
I'm ready to dip if I was that guy
fam if I was that guy let's say that was
his he's never done this before let's
just say he's never done this before
he's a random Joe he just out on a spat
do of his boys and he just wants to
skydiver see it he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] to do
as soon as that conversation happens
that's what I bought he be able to
concentrate the conversation because I
am petrified I'm not listening to a word
he says I'm petrified fall in yeah yeah
I'm thinking big man bear pull this soon
cuz my organs are feeling wrong you know
I mean what and as soon as he just lets
go of his own and he says you've got
this now pull this when the time's right
I'll scream what I will swim no to the
top of my lungs I'm suing as soon as I
land I'm sick I'm suing everyone
my solicitor as soon as as soon as I'll
take him the thing off I'm on the phone
I'm assuming everyone on the phone
everyone everyone bring me the CEO now
now these companies getting shut down
today because you can't risk my life for
your because you decided to die today
bro your time is your time because I
don't need that on me this is why I fear
life so much fear death so much because
you just never know that would that
would have been out of my hands out of
my hands and that's the [ __ ] with the
sea is out of your hands there's nothing
you can do to stop any animal inside the
sea from [ __ ] you up you're in their
territory you're in the unbeknownst this
is your problem now you chose this life
bro this is why I choose not to do
certain [ __ ]
I applaud and commend the people that do
these you like the mandem that work for
David Attenborough that do what he's I'm
woody Safari [ __ ] the way when we go to
[ __ ] Arctic Antarctica and I go to
[ __ ] in the depth of Africa for these
Safari [ __ ] I commend you man because as
as interesting and as lovely as it is to
watch you wouldn't you could never pay
me any amount of money to do that you
couldn't you couldn't bro pervert he's
on board or not pervy example but I've
gone I've got and am I the [ __ ] for
you mmm-hmm there was a video I haven't
even seen it I've heard the audio from
it yeah
in Italy ah a father and son were out
camping or some [ __ ] yeah and the mother
and the mama sister were there as well
but in this specific moment it was just
the dad and son yeah I'm coincidentally
dead they've been watching videos on
what to do if you see a bear okay and
apparently is like you just have to
slowly move away where are they okay
some forest in it okay okay okay so
they're watching this video like this
what you do yeah the kids like five and
lo and behold they're on this camping
trip or whatever and I will [ __ ] in
nowhere there's a [ __ ]
bear stalking the you stalking me you
know and that dad's like there's a
[ __ ] bear and they know and they have
to keep calm in it mmm my side in
Italian there's there's a bear walk
[ __ ] slowly breath come to me get in
the car as slowly as you possibly can
bro the little kid firms it Oh little
five-year-old firms it and the five year
old says dad put your camera on and
record it and that that actually does it
and I was I'll tell the whole story but
basically I was thinking is that an
[ __ ] for recording it hmm because in
a weird way if as long as I could go pro
ting or whatever and he doesn't have to
take his eyes off the situation yeah
like he's recording because it's on sort
of recording the same time it's like how
can you think about recording well your
son's life Steph your son's lives there
but anyway
thus the Sun firmed it cuz he firmed it
and had enough enough chess to be like
that [ __ ] record it and he did it he
moves slowly away these times the
[ __ ] mom and her sister are screaming
and they're like shut the [ __ ] up you're
gonna set him off
yeah yes screaming they're away away
this screaming and what I was thinking
to be that dad this is what this is the
thing is what obviously the kid must
have be scared he's gonna die off like
that to be that dad because when you're
that dad you know for a fact that your
son will not die mmm you're gonna you're
gonna die yeah because as soon as that
bear starts moving you're jumping in
your job drugs you're dead
yeah your son's gonna be fine you're
[ __ ] dead no matter what no matter
why that's scary as soon as that bed
like you're out of danger right now your
son's the one is after and he's doing
all the right moves so you're scared for
your son but deep down you know vasee
you're you are [ __ ] dead he doesn't
because you don't have the option I'm
thinking okay if this creeper waiting
doesn't work
cuz if it's just him is that all right
cool
it's just me by myself or me and my boys
or whatever does a bear guys [ __ ]
move slow move slow and if the bear no
offense if the bear comes for you I'm
different I know we're running alright
yeah you're running I'm running Rams
running Jays when everyone in every
direction I'm sorry yeah
I'm sorry I'll scratch fan I love you
and I'm sorry and I'm run oh I know I'm
not doing is gone but for that man he
doesn't have the option of running he
literally doesn't have the option of
running as soon as Donnie stands on his
hind legs but the dad has to sprint
sorry brah the dad has to sprint towards
the bear wow you have to run into your
death
that's an ever level of bravery and it's
not even bravery it's a non-negotiable
it's a vital flight but you you you have
to do it you have to do it it's labor
fire your life is done as soon as Donnie
stands up you don't even know if he's
gonna charge you still don't know what's
gonna happen but as soon as he reacts
you have to run you have to run at the
[ __ ] bear and kill yourself so your
son can live what a mad predicament what
a mad predicament to know to know to
know that your son has nothing to fear
he's gonna be alright even though it's
the bet it's that's him the Bears after
the bear was nothing to do with you the
bear wants this quick kill this
five-year-old kill he wants that
now cuz he's gonna get he's gonna get
dad and I'm fighting him you're gonna
lose in a second like back like that
lost before you started
you can't even swing it because swing a
bear I don't know if it will claw you to
do nothing if I was going camp next time
I go camping I've never been
never will if I ever go camping and
there's a possibility that bear might be
there I wanna have a machete
I want a knife knife a man's knife
because if I have to skirt with a bear
yeah I wouldn't at least feel like I
have a shot yeah even though even though
a knife ain't gonna do [ __ ] I want to
feel like I have an opportunity my bare
hands ain't doing [ __ ] they're not doing
[ __ ] the bear will run me the [ __ ] over
and he'll eat me for pleasure for
pleasure it would take time e me I'll be
screaming screaming that is crazy I
being a parent is a crazy thing you
would lay down your life in a second
don't think twice bag done you ain't
running it's okay it's gonna be all
right because I'm dead I'm dead soon as
dawn he stands up at his hind legs I
have to run at the best you know what
you know what's crazy when you said if
it was me you J if it was the boys and
the bear chased me we're all obviously
running in different directions and
you're like [ __ ] it I'm sorry do you not
think how crazy that is that that is
actually the wild like David
Attenborough I remember seeing I've seen
loads obviously but as soon as you said
they are just reminding me of a time
where I think a Jaguar or a tiger was
taste chases her like a family of deer
or something
and obviously deer drink and herd in
packs in [ __ ] packs so when the lion
or whatever is chasing all of them and
then it happens to pinpoint one and
you're that one oh my god oh oh my god
waiting cursed Lord when do you figure
out that you were the one is chasing you
think he's just chasing everyone and
then all of a sudden you realize that
everyone's over there and everyone's
over there and you're you're in the
distance it's 1v1 now Pro and I've seen
it what I've seen it where I think it
was he could have been a dealer like a
novice I don't it was faster they aren't
always fast but it was young for the
young guns the likelihood of it
surviving is so slim
so obviously that the tiger ever knew
that I was chasing it but when I say
time Jim was chasing for time the other
hood they were gone dear sponsor
they would watch it now they're watching
your boy died yeah and they've got
nothing because there's nothing they can
do about it nothing they was chasing it
for time the thing was fast it was going
coming I think it oh my god it might
escape and I was really in for it yeah
bro you know there was your watch never
never and you're rooting for it you
thumb get the [ __ ] away get the [ __ ]
away because these men are dangerous cuz
if you don't they don't play don't if
you don't take the right turn now your
life is over life is over bro and then
it was chasing it chasing it chasing it
got so close but you know they're ones
where the line has been running for ages
so he's tired but my mind's more unfair
it's equally as tiring is smaller but
because of the fear it keeps going and
keeps going and there's a point there's
a point of Hope when you think it makes
it and then as soon as it reaches a
point where there's still rain each
other and the deer offs or whatever
buckles oh I hate when that happens and
it buckles and your heart bleeds for it
because you think oh my god bro so all
of that is about to die exactly what you
just said about the buckling thing in
Australia in Australia I want to say
it's dogs they've got like pack dogs or
something yes Martha mmm they're smart
they when they're hunting kangaroo they
can never catch a kangaroo a kangaroo is
for us about fast they will never catch
a kangaroo and I can't go we'll just
jump over them and everything and I was
[ __ ] rapping yeah they never catch
these kangaroo so what they do these
kangaroo like graze in on like a [ __ ]
steep hill mmm so instead of just
running Adam they will all collectively
run to the top of the hill and then
they'd all spread across the land at the
top of the hill and it will run down the
hill at the same time mmm to force the
kangaroo to run down the hill and
because the kangaroo is so [ __ ] fast
when they're going downhill they can't
slow down slow down
they can't think and they all push
buckle and as soon as they buckle
they're dead as soon as they belong they
[ __ ] dead it's very small it's very
small cuz otherwise it shows them trying
to catch the kangaroo the other way
never in a million years never in a
million years there's catalog gone did
you know the pouches in kangaroos are
like see-through like yeah
when you open up the power gypsy that
organ yeah yeah II never knew that until
like last month same blew my mind seeing
ribs and all sorts loom I think a DS
miner kushti and war there living is a
living organs and bones and [ __ ] it blew
me away
it's wild man the homeless wrap up I
need a piss what an episode it's good